however believe nation welcome to
another edition of Evan Carmichael show
I missed you guys we took a break off
the last show because it was
Thanksgiving happy Thanksgiving to all
my American friends but we are back
we're going to close out the year strong
we're going to help you achieve your
goals for 2015 and I'm really excited to
have you on the show today so the topic
a really important one today is how to
beat procrastination and get work done
hey procrastination is one of the
biggest challenges I think especially
entrepreneurs have to go through now
this could be one day when you are
flying high you know you lend it a big
deal you listen to some somebody's radio
show you have a fantastic you meaning
whatever it is and you're you're on top
of the world nothing can stop you feel
like your goals are totally reachable
you're on fire you're working you're
going crazy and then the next day you
wake up and all of that energy seems to
be gone you know where did it go and
you're starting over from scratch and I
think as entrepreneurs especially we
fall into this trap and we as a result
for questioning we don't do the things
that we need to do we don't make
progress towards our goal we end up kind
of being aimless and lots not quite sure
what to do next and that will be back
and so today's show is dedicated to help
when you beat that procrastination and
start achieving the goals you have and
the business that you want all right
let's figure out how to be
procrastination the number one thing
that's most important is designing a
supportive environment and a lot of us
don't have environments that support us
you haven't designed your environment on
purpose and your result of not just the
five people who are your friends right
you've heard that expression isn't you
the average of your five friends that's
true but it's more than that it's also
your result of of the environment in
your office you know what's up on your
wall what media you consume what books
you read what you do in your spare time
what your hobbies are that sheets you
and you can either just react to the
world and be constantly putting out
fires only in the design an environment
that supports you that build you up that
helps you stay inspired that helps you
beat your fascination so when you walk
into your office what do you see I don't
care if you're working at a at a big
office you know you've had success in
your growing and you've got the top top
floor in some big building or if you're
working out of your home and you're in
the basement right whatever wherever
you're working from you're working from
somewhere and that space has to be a
place that inspires you and uplifts you
so when you walk into your office what
do you see you have to walk into my
office you're going to see a Steve Jobs
picture and one of my favorite quotes by
him that embodies beliefs hoping I'm all
about you're going to see some of my
favorite books on my book shop but each
one of those reminds me of an important
message that I want to leverage in my
business you'll see a statue of a
warrior a Chinese warrior Guan Yu whose
story i love you know there are things
in here that inspire me to want to go
and achieve my bigger goal so to step
outside my comfort zone to go and do
something bigger if you're in the
basement what a lot of entrepreneurs
have is that basement office mentality
and I'm not saying you have to go and
get this huge office I'm not saying you
have to go and take out the huge rent to
start off I actually recommend against
that you know you want to start small
you want to save your capital you want
to invest as you grow but you don't want
have the basement office mentality
that's the problem that a lot of people
have is when you walk into your office
even though it's in the basement you
feel like you're walking into a basement
and that limits your thinking that
brings you down when you walk into that
office you should feel uplifted and
inspired so what can you put in there to
help you it was close on the wall if
it's your favorite books if it's a
statue of something if it's a vision
board whenever it is you got to walk
into your office and create an
environment that is designed to build
you
a lot of us have a little man in our
life whereas the person who tells us
that we can't do it we're not good
enough find all the reasons why your
business idea is not going to work out
it could be your friend it could be your
family sometimes even yourself that
little voice that doubts in the back
your head saying you can't do this
you're not going to hit that goal need
the design an environment without little
man doesn't exist when you walk into
your office that little man is not
allowed in there I need to surround
yourself with people who build you up
surroundings up with friends who love
what you're all about who encouraged you
who give you support and drown out the
noise of the little man and knock it
also be reading stores remember when I
was first getting started you know I
didn't have an environment of
entrepreneurship my family they weren't
entrepreneurs you know they kind of
support of what I was doing but they
couldn't give me advice they didn't you
know give me that model to follow and so
I didn't have that environment so I had
to go and create it and what I do is I
started reading stories of famous
entrepreneurs I read stories of people
like Bill Gates and Donald Trump and
Oprah Winfrey and how these guys got
started you know 0 to 1 how did they
just get started and by reading their
stories constantly this is grateful
called radicals and visionaries that was
put up by entrepreneur press and I would
read a section of that every single day
basically tells famous stories I read
that every day a new story 23 pages and
it got me jacked up and helped me
realize that all of these famous
entrepreneurs they started with nothing
they didn't start with you know rich
parents who funded everything for them
they started with a dream and an idea
and often in absolute poverty and they
made it happen and so I made that part
of my environment to help me realize
that I could be like those guys too so
what you want to do is consciously
design an environment that supports you
right now I want you to think about
three things that you can do to improve
your environment three things that you
can do to put something up on the wall
read a book every day watch a YouTube
channel every day
three things I want you to make that
lips write it down three things that you
could do right now to improve your
environment to make it something that
can build you up because if you don't
change your environment you're always
going to have that basement office
mentality you can escape when you
believe it can escape you can escape
when you change your mindset and that
comes from changing your environment
okay so that's that tip number one now
how to beat procrastination create a
supportive environment number two is
have a big why you got to be motivated
right why are we doing this business too
many entrepreneurs they start a company
just trying to make money they start a
business because they have this goal I
want to make a hundred thousand dollars
i want to make a million dollars
whatever I want to make 25,000 whatever
it is you have this monetary goal and if
that's your only goal you're never going
to make it if you look at the richard
branson's of the world with steve jobs
of the world the oprah winfrey's of the
world big-name highly successful
entrepreneurs who've made it who've
accomplished their to mingle had a huge
impact on the world who who are
billionaires they got there not because
money was their goal they got there
because it had an important why there
was an important reason why they started
their business Oprah Winfrey I remember
was saying yes when she discovered this
top show idea which he did her first one
I came off and for her it felt like
breathing and she wanted to go in and
help continue to inspire millions of
people and she said she would do that
and take on two part-time jobs just to
make ends meet because she loved doing
it so much that's what you need this
Barney you need to have an impact Steve
Jobs the multi-million areas early
twenties and he kept going until the day
he died at Apple because he wanted to
have a huge impact money was never the
goal and yes you need to make money okay
this is not a charity you're not doing
it for charity you have to make money
but money is not the primary goal the
goal is to have an impact and when you
do that and you add a lot of value to
people's lives then you're going to make
money in the process
that's how it works what a lot of
entrepreneurs do when money is their
focus is say okay I gotta make this I
gotta make this hundred thousand dollars
whatever it is you just jump from idea
to idea to idea just trying to make
money and you don't stick with anything
long enough because you don't love it
you guys have the passion you got to
feel it you got to be you have to feel
like you're waking up everything and
doing something important right if
you're waking up every day and feeling
like the work you're doing is not
important then you're going to
procrastinate you're going to put it off
you're going to search you're going to
get distracted you're going to do under
things so you have to have a big why you
have to wake up feeling excited and
motivated that you're about to do
something today to go have a positive
impact on the world mine is the help of
billion entrepreneurs that's my personal
goal that excites that's why do this
radio show that's why I have my youtube
channel so I have my website you need to
find what your big why is have a big
goal write it down put it on the wall
put it in front of you put it in your
office put it in your bedroom so you
look at that every day and your Rita and
you get excited you read it and help
stamp out the procrastination you read
it and it makes you want to go and just
something big number three is now have
little wise and a little why are the
constant daily reminders to help you
realize that you're doing important work
that big goal that you have that helps
keep you motivated that helps to keep
you on track right I want to have a
building entrepreneurs but sometimes
that being Vulcan seem too big and can
seem too daunting so what helps are the
little wise and what I want you to do is
start thinking about things that that
you've done recently commented upcoming
some customers that keep you feeling
excited you know what now my my little
wiser I login to my youtube channel
every day my social media and and
there's a great comments right I put out
a new video and people right back would
say thank you everyone so much i love
these videos and i guess you know 50
comments a day coming in on my social
media that keeps me excited that keeps
me knowing that the stuff that I'm doing
matters to people but you may not be
there yet right
you may not have that kind of momentum
yet but you can get your feedback from
customers when I was first getting
started I would save the best feedback
that I had some customers put it into a
powerpoint file and I would look at that
PowerPoint file every day and that would
help keep me motivated and help me
remember that the work I'm doing is
important like people value what I'm
doing and looking at that every day it
made me feel that obligation that sense
of responsibility that I owed it to
people to continue going to keep pushing
harder to keep rowing this same because
people are counting on me so put
together a list of the feedback is
coming from your customers printed i'll
put it on your wall look at that every
day and how fit remind you that you're
doing important work anything that you
need to keep going I like it to the
calls I have Regina underline Regina
where you from and how can I help okay
i'm from Murfreesboro Tennessee and
owned two small restaurant and bars and
I was just wondering how I can mark it
better to bring in more customers what
what kind of food you have what kind of
a strong basically more bar than it is
restaurant we have fryers and a grill so
we have like a small menu of
cheeseburgers and burgers chicken strips
wings that kind of thing so what's
different about your bar why am I going
to go to yours instead of someone else's
well my weight or my bartenders and
waitresses wear booty shorts and chats
the restaurant bar industry is one of
the highest failure rates in America
everybody wants to start up a bar in a
restaurant a lot of them don't have
enough is that stand out the
differentiates I'm right if I'm if it's
fight night and I want to go to a bar to
enjoy it why am i picking yours versus
somebody else's so the film okay so we
got the waitresses what else am I going
to get when I come to your bar that's
going to prevent me from going somewhere
else I guess that's where I'm stuck I'm
trying to figure out what that is I mean
I know I've got the waitresses are the
waitresses and bartenders dress to bring
people there to see that
aspect of it I mean because we felt that
we needed bars and restaurants and our
little community like one of my bar and
restaurant is the only one in Unionville
Tennessee where as the one in
Murfreesboro though it's on the
outskirts of Murfreesboro Tennessee
going into Shelby though and there's not
any roadside bars or anything like that
through that areas for people to go tape
why not build around that community
pride like if people come in and feel
like hey I started this business because
union bill needs a bar make it about
unionville and how special that city is
our town or whatever union bill is and
if it's you know catering the people
passing by you can you can showcase how
great your little town is so that's why
you started it right you wanted to have
something local to show off you know
what you're all about and have something
for the people to come and enjoy right
well so if you make it why not make it
all about unionville or each location
about their own their own spot I know
you can also partner up with local
businesses that say hey you know we need
to we need to put unionville on the map
people should come here the destination
site and have them help promote you to
like you've given them something to
share to talk about beyond just oh yeah
there's a bar that they have waitresses
and that are cute and okay I can try
that but it's got to come from a place
of passion right but you have to really
want to put mean bill on the map so I
ask you why did you start this business
because because our local place needs a
bart right that started from that desire
within you right yes well in our
customers as well because when the one
we have in Murfreesboro on the outskirts
of microscope doing outdoor Shelbyville
we would have customers come in they
couldn't get there that often to it was
such a drive for them and then so we
took our customers into it and that's
how we ended up with the second winning
unionville because they were off
if we just if it was just closer to home
so um you know we just the mountain to
Mohammed she kind of like right would it
be great for your place to be is a
meeting place you know where where
people can come in and watch the watch
the game watch the fights but also meet
after work right and if you think about
the starbucks why do people go to
starbucks persons of dunkin donuts a big
go is there to have meetings and should
hang out and to have fun and enjoy a
drink right so I that would be back to
be your location to your just targeting
those people who care about the city and
partnering up with the local businesses
like the fastest way to grow business is
a partner up partner people who already
have your target audience so host event
and partner with local businesses to
have them promote something that's going
on at your event right is there like a
local think about the local businesses
there are right this is a local karate
school and local salsa dancing school
whatever it is right if there's an event
happening around that you can work with
them to promote it out of your bar you
know if there's a big video game
tournaments happening and there's a
local group of video gamers you can work
with them into hate we're going to we
want this to be the place and you kill
that everybody comes to we're going to
shows our game up on the screen bring
your people up you become known as the
place in the city to work with with
local businesses to attract those
customers coming in okay that sounds
great so it starts with that pride like
why we're doing this I want I want to
put the city on the map and then working
with local businesses who can tap into
that pride and help you promote the
various event that you going to put on
make sense makes absolutely in a percent
chance and I appreciate your feedback
all right no cobbler Gina things are
calling in good luck all right thank you
no problem and for all you lift me
remember one you got to stanford up
right why you started this business that
has to be important it's not just to
make money attached it to have two girls
in your heart serious business for a
reason and
the fastest way to grow as a partner up
find people who have your Terry aren't
you can connect with and have them help
these really business today I'm talking
about how to beat procrastination and
get work done so recap we've talked
about number one career supportive
environment number to have a big why
you're doing it because it's a big
reason number three have little wise and
these are the daily reminder some
customers and people who you top that
you can show that hey I'm doing
important work and I feel good I want to
keep doing it Jack number four commit to
someone as an entrepreneur it's funny
because we want our freedom we want not
to have a boss and then as a result we
don't always do the things that we need
to do to grow our business because
there's no one watching over us right we
don't have a boss tally mouth hey this
is important you got to get this done we
are our own bosses and as a result we
tend to do the things that we're
comfortable doing right the things that
don't really stretch our comfort zone
the things that don't really push us to
be better who pushes you to be better
who pushes you to be the best version of
yourself that to believe in you to say
hey I think you can go further she needs
to commit to other people when you
commit to somebody when you say hey I'm
going to do this then you more likely to
follow through right when you make that
promise to somebody you'll break a
comments to yourself a lot faster then
you'll break a promise to somebody else
right you want to look bad you want to
make them think badly of you so you're
more likely to follow through so use
that to your advantage this whole thing
you've been putting off even for
Christ's inated on convince with
somebody else and tell them that you're
going to do it and let me give an
example so for a while I've wanted to
put together a series where I go out on
video an interview and profile local
businesses in my area and I don't know
for whatever reason I've been putting it
off you know I I feel like that's going
to be a big time commitment I don't know
what it's going to look like I'm afraid
it's not going to work out you know it's
going to be worse all that time to put
into it and and four months I've kind of
put it off and then I decide you know
what I'm going to email I'm going to
email one business
and I'm going to let them know here's my
idea what do you think I think he said
I'm all on board let's do it and so
tomorrow I'm not trying next week next
week I have to go and do the first in
the series right I've committed to her
we set up a time and so now I got to go
out and do it right I'm reading my own
procrastination to go out and do it so
committed somebody out there that that
minute will you get boldness you know
you live enough we all live in this
bubble right we live in this bubble that
we're pushed down by our own limited
personal beliefs and every now and then
we get that courage and we get that
moment of inspiration saying i think i
could be more than what I am now and you
actually truly believe it right it's a
fleeting moment and then it may be a
minute later an hour later a day later
life kind of knocks you back down to
where you were before you got to take
advantage of that minute of courage that
minute of boldness and start taking
immediate action when you feel like I'm
ready to jump out I feel like I can do
this take action right away and commit
to somebody you're thinking about doing
an interview you're thinking about
making a video series like I was when
you have that minute of boldness send an
email to somebody they use what i want
to do are you interested don't wait
don't plan don't make an Excel
spreadsheet don't keep thinking about
what you're going to do next is go out
and make a commitment to somebody and
you're more likely to follow through on
that it's going to push you to stretch
your comfort zones guys the number four
is committed someone else I want to get
to the calls i have Joey on the line
Joey where are you from and how can I
help hey hey dude lol in New York now I
spoke with you a while back about I get
more business you know whether DJ deuce
is no to ya DJ comedian singer yes yes
yes so a lot of the follow up with you
and what I really did was I updated the
website and I pushed it on on social
media yeah and I got I got the word out
there and I really got motivated after
our conversation and I did book a couple
I talked about two jobs and from those
jobs just by doing those jobs I gave out
cards and I had people interested for
future so just had to take a step
forward and just really you know i think
i was lazy with you know with the
website i think that's a huge you know
the Internet is huge and I wasn't using
it awesome do you have the video up to
no I have a bunch of video footage
actually just yesterday I made a YouTube
page we're going to put the videos of
all that stuff arm it's just going to be
for business owners stuff every and you
know anything about business on that
cage and I want to post that on social
media as well okay so let me let me kind
of region my memory and also remind our
listeners you were doing DJ gigs but you
also had the comedy and singing show
that you wanted to introduce but you
couldn't get the corporations to say
yeah we want that were too tiring for
the DJ business all right right right
all right all right enjoy you texted my
memory yeah there's I'm safe it's they
will be interfaced with an episode
before the nose talk about a plane it's
safe to follow the DJ and I was trying
to push you know all my talents and 21
into Laurel parties I guess they'll be
different to get there to get more work
yeah and you know what corporations are
safe right like nobody wants to hire the
wrong guy and that makes that person
look foolish and they get fired over
right there they are Dave birds exactly
Hey yes I enjoyed it combat that you
reduce the risk by showing them what
they're going to get right like you
could talk about it as much as you can
to you could blue in the face but it's
often it's going to fall on deaf ears
and it's greatly has been successful far
with the web the next step really is
like show me show me what I'm going to
get right make that video maybe your
neck of the gig you can do it or just do
your own thing and get your friends to
film it put it all to god hath you can
stay here dwell looks like i have been
videotaping i have been been using my
iphone which is HD it's pretty clear let
me believe it up yeah it's better than
nothing and you know I've been putting
them all into a folder on my desktop
and now I just want to cut them down
edit them down just to the good parts
you know just to the you know to get me
rolling all the garbage that's on it and
edit it down to like a two or three
minute video and then I'll gonna push
that on the website as well as the
social media but yeah just taking
advantage of you know the internet it's
one thing I was lacking I was doing a
lot of word-of-mouth people call me
explaining it over the phone it's so
much easier to tell people over my
website and you know I'm graph to you
and having the courage to take your
iPhone and do it there's a lot of
entrepreneurs if you like on the camera
I don't know anybody has a camera and
they just procrastinate surprise me
procrastinate you can get started with
an iphone you can meet know it enough
video off an iphone to show what you're
all about I'll tell you the truth the
quality is the quality it's really good
I mean it lily is the quality of an
iphone is data is not bad at all and
it's like my fun time I was telling me
it's better than nothing then those kind
of not having anything you know you
don't have to go all out and get the
best there you go in the middle
sometimes yeah I mean and then maybe
that leads to more gig and not lead to
be able to charge more that leads to
being able to invest in better gear and
equipment you start with what you have
when you have it and you continue to
build but my thank you to you is
motivating me with with the internet and
with social media is that that
definitely opened up a lot of doors
today and now I'm more confident now
that this is going to work off the man I
love it so I appreciate the last phone
call we had because before that I feel
like I was just I was thinking
everything but I wasn't doing it you
know it you could think it out and think
it out for months and but the thing is
to get your foot down and just do it you
know follow through with you you know so
and I did I did I did after the last
hope never actually sort of tape and
every gig goes out after that I'm a nice
folder full of video and I'm gonna get
to work on that as well I love it you
would drop your website one more time
for everybody listening ok so the
website now is super DJ entertainment
soon I DJ pre-interview name of Dominum
com loving
thank you so much for calling back in I
love hearing your program thank you so
much I appreciate everything all right
take care bye-bye forever for everybody
listening jewelry has such an important
message man you've got to get out of
your head stop claiming your business to
death right as entrepreneurs are often
over planners we plan to plan the plan
we playing with try to get the perfect
plan together you get results from doing
yes you need to plan but you know what
your client is going to change the
minute you start doing and I'm not
saying just do in every direction but
don't plan yourself to death stop just
creating Excel spreadsheets give him a
folder that you're going to get to
someday because someday is not a day of
the week Joey started he took the advice
from the last show he created a website
he started on social media he's making
videos with his iphone and he's got
business he's got a couple of new
clients he's got momentum he's kind of
place to send people and it may not be
perfect it's going to get better each
time but he has started don't let the
lack of a perfect plan hold you back
from starting stop planning your
business to death today I'm talking
about ways to beat procrastination and
get work done quick recap we've talked
about 1 create a supportive environment
that inspires you to have a big y and
not just doing it for the money three
having little why's that kind of daily
reminders from your customers people who
you're helping to give that extra little
boost to let you know you're doing
something important number forwards
commit to somebody else so you're more
likely to follow through number five
here we go do something that you love
you're going to do work that you love if
you wake up and you know you're going to
be doing work that you love but I call
it usually CEO time this is where
whenever I walk into the office it's
thinking what can I add value to my
business today what's the best use of my
time to add the most value today what am
I best in the world I feel I can bring
to my business today because when you're
working on those projects when you were
the big exciting world-changing
value-adding projects that keeps you
excited that makes you feel like you
want to go to work that helps beat out
the procrastination but when you are
thinking I gotta go do this but I have
these meetings that I don't want to do
and all these taps on my place that's a
procrastination gift man that that is a
time killer for you that's what breeds
the procrastination because you don't
want to do the work when you do the work
you don't procrastinate when you love it
you don't procrastinate so you got to
take it really hard look at your
schedule you want to eliminate automate
delegate as much as you can away as much
as the tacit you're not great at that
you don't enjoy that you're not the best
in the world I said you don't add a lot
of value to and start focusing on the
stuff that you love this te old time the
big picture thinking that's what's going
to help you get to your goals not doing
all of the grunt work and you may be
thinking I don't have the budget is out
I can't afford to do that I'm ready you
don't strapped for cash one you can
eliminate right there things that you're
doing that you shouldn't be doing at all
to automation software doesn't have to
cost you a lot of money simple things
like a counting software and save so
much time we're just trying to do
everything manually or in Excel and
three you're going to delegate then it
doesn't have to be bring on a full-time
worker the first guy hired was for one
hour a day one hour per day i paid them
I don't know 10 or 15 bucks an hour and
that seemed more than an hour a day of
my time because he was better at doing
that task and I was and that's freed up
an hour and a half of my time to vote
with on bigger picture stuff how much
happier would you be how much more
motivated would you be even if you just
got an hour and a half extra per day to
work on bigger picture of projects that
you love so you phase it in but taking
those small steps help build that
motivation and help stomp out
procrastination okay number six have a
routine that was five until the new lot
number six other routine you want to
have a daily routine that supports you
that builds you up I start my day
and put some music on you got to have
music on that makes you bounce your head
that makes you bought that makes you
want to move you know when you listen to
my show you hear this Latin music come
on between the segment I love that stuff
I love salsa and bachata you know
kizomba that stuff gets me going that
sucks brings you a lot that's why it's
on my show you gotta have music that
makes you [ __ ] a lot but gets you excited
and moving because when you are moving
when you're happy when you're excited
you're more likely to take action where
you're waking up and you're you know
you're slowly up and you're getting the
snooze button five times you're not
setting yourself up for success so you
start with music you remind yourself of
your big wide you remind yourself of
your little why you can create a daily
ritual that supports you right from when
you wake up you don't have to wait until
a meeting that you have a three o'clock
in the afternoon where you meet someone
and you get inspired by them you can
design it just like you design your
environment you can design a routine
that supports you that builds you up
that makes you want to go out and beat
that procrastination my last tip for you
guys number seven had a beat
procrastination and get work done is
join or create a mastermind group what
I'm ask my group is is basically an
informal Board of Advisors for your
business a lot of oxford's they have
nobody to to hold you accountable right
who will do countable when you say I'm
going to this goal who actually monitor
did you do that or not besides yourself
so I was frustrated that there wasn't
anything here in my city Toronto so I
built one here in Toronto the concept
comes from Think and Grow Rich if you
guys have ever read it awesome book
napoleon hill it's on my bookshelf and
you get together entrepreneurs from
different backgrounds around the same
kind of skill level but with different
skills so if i'm really good at
marketing i want some of this good of
operations I want someone was good at
fundraising I want some as good at
technology and you help fill each
other's weaknesses and you come together
how we do is we meet once a month
physical location actually have my
meeting tonight it's a second thursday
of every month of us tonight we're
meeting downstairs and it does two
things
one of the film in your blind spots
right so you are surrounded by people
who are good at things that you're not
good at and by having those people in
the room you could help them with their
business they can help you with your
business they can give you suggestions
and feedback and ideas of how to grow
and resources and connections and access
the people that you wouldn't have access
to otherwise and it has to come from
that spirit of wanting everybody else to
be successful right you're not in it
it's not a networking group we're not
here to exchange business leads leads
end up happening business ends up
happening because you're the only one
that's what you do but it's not the
point of the group we're here to try to
help each other ever so you get lots of
great ideas and in connection to help
you grow your business but the second
component and it's just as important
it's the motivation how many other
entrepreneurs do you know a lot of
entrepreneurs don't know a lot of other
entrepreneurs it'll have a network of
entrepreneurs to talk to and share
things with when you go to a meeting
you're all talking about the good things
in your business right this new customer
you landed how you launching the website
and its grapes but you talk to you about
the bad stuff in your business who you
talk about all that other things that
you're worried about it I don't know if
I can keep doing this to me one thing
we're going back in a job who you tell
that to that's the point of the group as
well it's a sounding board it's
motivation it's knowing that other
people are going through the same thing
that you're going through it's knowing
that you're not alone so you can look in
your area see if there's a mastermind
group and if not you can create one
right all you do I start a group with
four member for members and build it up
to eight and that time action so you
find three other people in your area who
have a business who wanted idea bring
them together and will help your
business grow it's been an awesome week
again thank you guys so much for staying
in quick recap but seven ways to beat
procrastination get work done number one
creates a supportive environment to have
a big y 3 you have little wise or commit
to some 15 do something you love six
have a routine seven join accreta
mastermind group I want to make that
name again Thank You Christy Thank You
Josh you guys are often my producers I
will be on again in two
until then continue to believe you can
you two grow and I will see you soon
don't forget to click here to subscribe
to my newsletter to get actionable
inspiring motivational believe advice
every single week to your inbox hi i'm
jason j reyez fonseka of ra's online
calm and i want to say Evan Carmichael's
newsletter is consistent fun inspiring
and XD only newsletter i prioritize and
look forward to period